okay so walk me through
the day that the bridge was struck by
the ship
what were you guys doing like that
morning how long have you had you guys
been working together at that point
can that can you walk me through that
day sure i'll
i'll start go ahead bob if i can fill it
mike was interviewed and hired on may
2nd which was a friday
uh i called him up friday afternoon
and uh told the report to work on monday
so
technically he was hired on the second
came into work monday
got his equipment and his gear dive shop
showed them around the office told them
what our responsibilities were
got them all geared up went to the
tackle shack in pinellas park and got us
some equipment and stuff
explained to them what were
responsibilities were
spent some time diving at the skyway
with mike
prior to may 9th we did a couple of
dives
at within within 200 yards of that
location
where the bus fell on the water we were
inspecting the fender system
what was what was left of the fender
system the fender system was a big issue
it wasn't protected as it should have
been not my
wheelhouse way before my time what what
do you mean when you say fender system
by the time i started in 1974 the timber
fender system that was built on that
structure to protect both of them
had been demolished by ship traffic
there was very little protection
absolutely there was no no protection
uh to speak up for any large vessels as
obvious
as was obvious uh so we spent a couple
of days diving out of that location in
this couple of days before that
so actually by may 9th
he had only been with me two or three
dives
and actually five working days
and mike put it very very well when we
were being interviewed
uh by the times that's like somebody
now joining the new york fire department
on september 6th and then walking up the
stairs on september
11th mike had no idea neither did i
that morning on friday
may 9th when we got to the yard
when we got to pinellas maintenance yard
dot yard at the intersection almost to
49th and olmerton
it was pretty miserable out it was rainy
that was what the forecast was
i had a
portable radio on my hip called the
office
told me we were going to step out
we hopped in the car at about seven
o'clock in the morning
after we met and we knew we were gonna
have a long day because we were headed
out to the skyway
after the weather cleared we stopped
down at a restaurant local restaurant
called the bunny hut we
we're going to get some coffee and some
some breakfast and stuff
and at 7 34 give or take
the girls came out from the back and
started talking about the skyway got
knocked down
and they were pretty excited sounded
pretty real
that was it was kind of a bad joke and
and not a
unusual one for the guys you know to
always give us the business or me the
business about you know this bridge got
hit and this
went down you got to do this you got to
do that and stuff so it was kind of like
teasing me so
when they came out like my first thing
was okay
they brought the radio out and uh i
heard i think it was al
ford the sky and the
guy in the sky and he was on the radio
and he was talking about it he said the
skyway had been hit
and it's down and they were uh
serious i remember they had tvs going
too
they may have seen some live footage
from from the restaurant of the
of the accident yeah so we
hopped in the car went back to the yard
the boss saw there was a ron hazel if he
was already on the radio we knew we were
headed out there it was our duty our
responsibility
to investigate any waterborne
accidents that was our position
description that's what we did
when we realized it was for real uh
nobody needed to tell us to get out
there we knew
we had to get out there so we scooted
back to the yard it took us less than
five minutes
we were out of there before eight
o'clock
with our gear because we were headed
down that way anyways and the boat
we hopped on overton and at that time
they were just
on and off completing the bypass 275
from up around auburn on down south to
the skyway there were portions of it
were asphalt and portions of or still
dirt
we had a 16 foot boston whaler with a
tank rack six tanks and
threw all our gear in there and hooked
it up to the back of the station wagon
and zipped as fast as we could down the
partially built interstate zipping on
and off when we couldn't
go around any further due to the
construction i think we got off
someplace around
fifth avenue north or something i think
that's right i remember the high school
i'm pretty sure we probably ran the curb
a couple of times and maybe even jumped
the curb a couple of times
maybe even cut some corners a couple of
times we got down there as fast as we
could
we got down to 54th avenue south and the
police barricade was
up we identified ourselves and they
waved us through
we ran down to our normal launch
location which was skyway jacks
the marina o'neals uh
we got dressed we launched the boat
there wasn't much traffic there at that
time it was just us we were still kind
of early
and started to head out from skyway
jacks
to the bridge at our location once we
got out of the mouth of the uh
the small
philippe creek
the small marina once we get out of the
small marina
and got out there it was completely
fogged up uh it was very very foggy
i had been out there numerous times
numerous times and
had a difficult time navigating out very
thick fog
yeah i couldn't see the channel mark i
mean from the reports
like watching the documentary they're
talking about how it was
like hurricane force winds and just
downpouring rain as well
that was that was obviously way earlier
yes that's absolutely correct
absolutely correct yep it was dead still
when we got out there because the fog
was
thick it was a fog bank almost solid
it's a coincidence because it broke so
that we could actually first time we saw
the bridge
was where the current skyway memorial
is okay for the very first time is where
that memorial is today it was where we
started to see that yeah right
so where the blackthorne memorial is you
know it's almost like fate or something
that that was there
from that location we could see the
bridge i could see that the bridge was
down
i could see that the boat was still
stuffed up underneath there
we headed out there
and the obvious location to start as far
as i was concerned was
at the end of the bridge because that's
more than likely
where we would start an inspection would
be to go ahead and start measurements
and stuff like that rather than just
drive around
look for something to do so what we had
definitely we had a
a plan start at that location and start
documenting what we had
we were on an accident investigation so
that's what we were doing
but when you guys first got in the boat
and put it in the water
had you guys communicated with anybody
about
what your mission was or what your
objectives were no
other than it's an accident
investigation get out there as fast as
you can
on the way down listening to the am
radio
we overheard that there was a bus that
did go off
and potentially 30 40
50 people were in the bus you know we we
did hear that we did hear that there was
traffic
that had driven off the bridge so we
knew that they were victims
we knew that there were cars and
vehicles and trucks and people
underwater yes so what were you guys
like talking to each other about like
what were you like what
what were you guys going to do once you
got there i don't think we were doing
much talking i think it was more just
trying to get down there and
you know it's really hard to grasp the
whole enormity of the situation until we
actually got there and could see what
was happening i
i think the when we saw these
students from eckerd college in the
water and their boats out there of
course we were already familiar with who
they were and what they would normally
be doing but when we could tell that
they were over the site of the
accident probably over the side of that
bus and that they had divers in the
water
at the same time working above the
dangling steel
super structure that was still in place
above them
that could potentially start dropping at
any second and
crash right down on top of them
i think we felt it was our duty to
relieve them
to move them away from danger and assume
that responsibility ourselves were the
state inspectors these these kids had no
business i don't think being out there
doing what they were doing although and
they were well-meaning
good intentions but taking an
unnecessary risk for uh
for nothing i thought i
i would i agree in large part with mike
i don't think the kids had any say in
where they anchored up i'm pretty sure
it was the
person who was responsible for you know
for the rescue operation
let me let me say this before i go any
further
mike and i completely understand
that if it wasn't for those kids
and that equipment being there
that we would have never been able
to accomplish what little
we could under those circumstances
it would have been very nice to have a
little more
cooperation from the man in charge
but the kids were fantastic
all of them there was only one
person that was being a ding-dong and he
was quickly ignored
we never asked them to
that location we simply asked them to
back off a little bit
so that we could take that
responsibility
like mike said my opinion was they were
directly in the flight path of anything
coming off of that bridge anything
we only went under there after i picked
up my radio
and asked my supervisor who was up there
ron who was a bridge inspector if it was
safe and if it was okay for us to go
under there
so we had communications with top side
people when we were out there and he did
say yeah bob you got it